(whooshing)
- Amjazzy96, how do we
communicate with people
who are difficult to work
with when we have to?
- Oh.
- What do you think?
- Wow, yeah, now, god,
there's loads of like
behavioral psychology on
this, and I guess hey amjazzy
it sounds like it's an environment.
With customers, I'll be
honest, I never find them hard
to communicate, especially if
we talk about social media.
It sounds like when you
get in the situation,
it might not be for you guys,
but if you got a relationship
that's a bit prickly with your
boss or something like that,
then that is a position
that can be a bit feisty.
So I think it comes back
to some of the basics
Evan has touched on, is
number one, we kind of have
to put ourselves at the
center of the conversation,
and put ourselves in their
shoes, and then ask ourselves
what is it they want and
why are they behaving
the way they are?
'Cause normally things are pretty logical.
And then the other
thing that I touched on,
all the sort of behavioral
psychology stuff,
is reality is the beauty of the world is
everyone's got a different personality.
And the reality is
different personality types,
some get on with each other,
some want to go to a Blue
Jays game all the time
and they want to hang out an drink beer,
some people don't want to do that.
Some people want to listen to music.
Some people want to read books.
And therefore, I just think
we've got to accept that
one of the beauties in life
is we're totally different.
And I think the tolerance
of that is definitely good.
Now if it all gets tough,
I think that there's loads
of stuff you can do in
terms of go to a mentor.
Ask someone independent,
kind of this is happening,
this is the situation.
It could be with a customer.
It could be with one of
your work colleagues,
someone who works for
you as an entrepreneur.
And particularly if you're an entrepreneur
and you're asking someone
in the team to do something
and it's kind of not landing
or it's poor quality,
or they're letting customers down,
you know I can understand that hurts.
And then 'cause what we said
before, it's very personal.
It's very personal.
You guys sacrifice a
lot, you work long hours,
you pursue your dreams,
and you want everybody
to pull the same level of weight as you do
in terms of that idea that
you're trying to get to market.
So there's other ways to help.
So I'd go first to mentorship,
and then ultimately
if you work out what is
the clock that's ticking
within the person that's
being challenging,
I'd always advocate being
honest with people and say
you know I don't think there's anything.
Someone taught me once,
yeah, there's probably
no bad people around.
It's just sometimes the
behaviors really upset us.
And I think if you sat down
with someone and said look,
you're not a bad person.
For whatever reason, we're not getting on.
I think broadly we want the same things.
I want to build this company.
I want to be the next Google.
I want everybody in the
company to follow this dream.
Let's just be honest with each other.
What's not clicking, what's not working?
'Cause you know I'm not perfect.
I think this is where you can
use a bit of self-deprecation
and share a bit of vulnerability.
I'm not perfect, but what is it
that's getting in the way here
'cause we all want the same things,
but we're bumping into each other.
So what can we do to just,
as they say in Canada,
get that moose on the table.
Get that moose on the table
and then we can break it
into a thousand pieces
and we can consume it
and sort it out and move on.
Yeah, I don't know.
Evan, any ideas?
- There it is again, that
customization to the audience.
I love it.
I mean I agree with
everything Stephen's saying.
I almost want to just copy and
paste, and I would encourage
you guys to watch that clip back again.
Those three points he
made were really good.
The only thing I would add
to it is I go into every
situation trying to take
full responsibility.
And I think if you
abdicate responsibilities
is when you start to
lose in all situations.
But here, as an example, as
soon as you label somebody
difficult, you're saying
it's their fault, right,
it's their problem.
They're the one who's hard to
deal with, they're difficult,
and that reduces some of
the responsibility on you
to navigate the situation.
Where if you just play back
that last piece Stephen
was talking about is that look,
everybody is a human being.
There's no bad people,
they just have different
circumstances, different
upbringings, different values.
And if you take the
responsibility to say I want
to navigate this, I want
to make it a success,
put it on yourself to figure it out,
then just going in with
that different mindset
I think could really help
you have more success
in the conversation.
On top of everything else
you've been talking about,
getting a mentor, trying
to understand them,
put yourself in their
shoes, it was really great.
See, I think I might have to
watch back that answer too.
I'm going to bookmark that one.
I like that one, that was real good.
(whooshing)